self-driving Robo taxis are already on
the road in two U.S cities and could
soon be coming to a place near you so
this morning we're taking a closer look
at what to expect in our series we're
calling it American innovation on the
transformative role of Science and
Technology in our lives it is here one
leading company is waymo it's app-based
it's at based rather ride hailing
service has been on the road for more
than six years now and currently
averages ten thousand passenger rides a
week waymo just announced a partnership
with Uber Chris Van Cleave climbed into
the back seat for a driverless ride
Robert Stone and Sheila ziglowski are
trying out waymo's ride hailing service
that just expanded to include their
Tempe Arizona retirement community their
car arrives without a person in the
driver's seat we love it it's just it's
going to replace a car for us before
sooner than later in 2018 CBS morning's
cameras were the first allowed to ride
in a fully autonomous waymo then the
service was limited to a select few
early adopters and each gas-powered
minivan arrived with a human safety
driver on board waymo doesn't tend to
completely remove the safety driver
eventually so there'll be no one up
front at all after more than a million
driverless miles and no reported
injuries waymo is seen as the industry
leader having expanded its footprint in
Phoenix adding service in San Francisco
and soon to parts of Los Angeles those
minivans have been replaced with a fleet
of all-electric jaguars the waymo driver
never gets drowsy it doesn't get
distracted it is something that is
attentive all the time Adam lens is
waymo's head of sustainability would you
say the cars perform as well or better
than a human driver I would say that I
really trust this technology and that
when you're in the car you feel entirely
safe and it's a great user experience
but the technology is still learning I
think there's opportunities to continue
to build a better service for our Riders
and we continue to do that in March 68
percent of drivers told AAA they were
afraid of autonomous vehicles though
truly self-driving cars are operating in
only a handful of cities across the
country it's really impressive what
waymo is doing the journalist Tim
Stevens covers the Auto industry if you
compare that to any other ride-sharing
company like an Uber or a Lyft that are
serving basically Coast to Coast at this
point is really a tiny impression waymo
is owned by Google's parent company
alphabet weibo has been given a lot of
Runway this far and a lot of r d dollars
to develop this you know truly
incredible technology but it is still a
long way away from being a truly viable
independent profitable business and so
the question on the minds of a lot of
people is how much more patience does
alphabet have for this business here in
San Francisco the city council denied
waymo a permit to add a parking garage
after concerns from the community and
labor unions that autonomous vehicles
could cost jobs
using the waymo app we tried it for
ourselves taking a ride around Phoenix
for about the same cost as calling an
Uber and you pretty quickly sitting back
here forget there's no one actually
driving the vehicle other than there's
no driver making awkward small talk
while we're going from point A to point
B there are a few little things that are
different it can be a little hesitant
and it's taken a couple of turns maybe
not the way a human driver would but
nothing that was unsafe what we've seen
is that people experiencing the
technology really leads to people using
it more and having trust and the
technology to get them safely to where
they need to go two people who don't
need to be convinced Sheila and Robert
I'm 83 years old and I'm thinking about
retiring from driving and this is just a
great way to go I can get rid of my car
and depend on it you don't have any kind
of mixed feelings about the fact there's
no one driving the car that's exciting
part it's fun and it's safe and you
don't have to tip
riding into a tipless and driverless
future
for CBS mornings I'm Chris Vancleave in
Phoenix
all right waymo they've been working on
it for a long time based on what we saw
there I thought it looks pretty good
sign me up I'm good with it oh yeah yeah
think about how many times you got in
the back of a car yeah you've been
distracted you fell asleep or you had a
bad driver oh you had a bad driver or
the driver won't stop talking to you you
find a way to distract yourself and not
pay attention it's the same thing I just
have a safer driver I think it'll help
with traffic because so many drivers at
red lights are just sitting on their
phones like this and then that's a good
point everyone yeah the computer just
goes the only thing it doesn't make up
for when you get in a car and you're in
a little bit of a rush and you lean up
there and you say hey how to get to the
airport in about 45 minutes that human
driver knows exactly what you're doing
yes it might push the limit a little bit
and sometimes the humidity the human
driver knows a couple little shortcuts
here and there that the computer does
not recommend that just happened to me
the other day because we go a little bit
faster than I went well I want to get
there alive yeah